- [Instructor] Let's get
some practice now thinking
about how ions typically form,
how they might form compounds
and how we name those compounds.
So let's start with
something in group one.
In this first column, this
first column is often known
as alkali metals.
So let's start with potassium.
K is the symbol for potassium.
Now things in group one here,
one way to think about
is their outermost shell
has one electron in it.
So they wouldn't mind
losing that electron.
So when they ionize, they
tend to lose an electron
and become a cation, a positive ion.
And so let's look at a situation
where I have some potassium
that has been ionized.
I could write it just like this,
we've seen that in previous videos
and we can refer to this
just as a potassium ion,
we could refer to this
as potassium one plus.
We could refer to this
as a potassium cation.
Now let's go on to the other
side of the periodic table.
Things that would really
love to grab an electron.
So things in group, in the halides,
which is this column right over here.
So these are the halides.
They have seven electrons
in their outermost shell.
They would love to have eight,
so they tend to be really
good at grabbing electrons.
And so let's say we're
dealing with chlorine,
and chlorine is able to ionize.
So it's able to grab an electron.
When chlorine grabs an electron,
it will be a negatively charged ion,
so you could write it
as Chlorine one minus,
but the way that we
generally refer to an anion,
a negatively charged ion,
instead of just calling
this the chlorine anion,
we would call this chloride.
So this we would refer to as Chloride.
Now as you can imagine
with potassium having
a positive one charge or one plus charge
and this having a negative charge,
they're going to be
attracted to each other
and they can actually
form an ionic compound.
The ionic compound they
would form, we would write
as, you'd write your positive ion first
and then you would
write your negative ion.
And this right over
here would be described
as potassium chloride.
Let me write that down.
Potassium, potassium chloride.
Now you might be saying, "Well, I just,"
Let me rewrite the whole thing.
So you know the chloride
part, you say okay,
this is going to be an anion
because instead of writing chlorine
which is the name of this element,
I wrote this IDE at the end
to say, "Hey, this is an anion,"
so I know that this is the
chlorine anion, this is chloride,
why didn't I do something
similar for potassium?
Well, the way the convention works
is if someone says potassium chloride,
you know you're dealing
with an ionic compound
and if the chlorine has
a negative one charge,
an ionic compound,
the whole thing is gonna be neutral.
So if this one over here is one minus,
then you know this over
here is just one-for-one,
this is going to be one plus
so you know that you're
dealing with a potassium cation
and you could say and a chloride
ion or a chlorine anion.
You could refer to it various ways,
but this is potassium chloride.
You have a positively charged potassium
and you have a negatively
charged chlorine,
which we would call a chloride.
In the next few videos I'll
do many, many more examples
of this and ones that will be
a little bit more complicated.